[Music]
so when I started building a satellite
constellation like the sky was the limit
like what am I gonna do I'm Gonna Save
the water
[Music]
so Fleet space technology is on a
mission to build a constellation of very
small satellites to solve the biggest
problem on earth and the first one that
we're tackling is looking for critical
minerals the minerals that kind of
underpin the energy transition of
humankind the next 20 years
so I've heard you say your satellites
are quite small they're the size of a
pizza box right tell us what's different
about your satellite versus a
traditional satellite my vision and my
dream was the traditional satellites
we're talking about billion dollar big
satellites probably as big as a bus so
it's always been kind of the game of the
big guys or government stage separation
confirmed it makes me feel lucky that
this is the time where I'm alive and I'm
contributing you know even if I'm not in
Silicon Valley
even if I'm not the usual profile of a
CEO founder of a tech startup I
contributing something big I was very
fascinated about the world had to go
through this amazing energy transition
solar panels electric car
electrification of the grids it's a big
big change for humankinds and need a
change for climate change and then you
look back and then realize we need 40
times more lithium four times more
copper and then it's kind of country
intuitive
that to save the world we need to drill
it so this is what I got passionate
about yes we are trying to find critical
minerals so we can go to Net Zero faster
like if you look at Fleet critical
minerals application we found a solution
so you have you can find critical
minerals but reducing 90 of your
drilling so you know using old data so
you can do 3D maps of the underground
without drilling they actually send
amazing you know ways that EQ you can
listen to for a few days and map up to
many many kilometers and say okay this
is lithium this is copper this is Rock
do you ever think about looking at Mars
other plants do you do that of course we
want to do that because Elon Musk and
Nas are going to Mars and going to the
moon and interesting things about this
new space right is that we are not just
going there to put a flag we are going
to stay so when you want to have people
living on other plot and what do you
need you need food water energy right
you need the basic so this space race is
less about rockets and more about how
can we sustain our human can and other
planets
foreign